so we know who's gonna be playing we
just don't know which side they're going
to be playing for but that's all about
to change because the captains are ready
LeBron James Jana senator kupo LeBron
because you were the leading vote-getter
overall that earns you the right once
again to have the first pick I think I
know who it's going to be I'm not gonna
say anything Charles and Kenny their
mics are open they they're here for
assistance if you if you need it at all
I don't know how likely that is LeBron
probably on likely but go ahead you got
the first pick and the slaughter was
your Hobbes you know Kent well you know
Kenny's name been coming up a lot and a
lot of GM conversations over the last
couple years the only right now my
recruitment is a young man in Sierra
Canyon in seventh grade
yeah that's the guy recruiting now for
my basketball
all right so with the number one pick in
a 2020 all-star game and this was tough
this was very tough and the only reason
I'm picking him because he happens to be
from this city
i'ma go with Anthony Davis as my number
one I think a stunned not surprised
I know y'all surprised I know this is
the big one for Yanis right here okay um
with my first pick I'm gonna go with my
African brother I'm I play against him
tonight but I think he's going big great
matchup for Anthony Davis I'm gonna go
with Julian beat what page of that book
was that on there that pic okay that's
about 15 pages deep okay very good
LeBron with the second pick I know we
have a lot to go on here in Los Angeles
you know there's a lot been talked about
between us and them and them and us but
for this weekend we will be teammates
and I'm gonna go with Kawhi Leonard Wow
it's not it's an all la team LeBron at
riot point yes LA vs. the world yes oh
that's what it is right now I need cake
I like to see I'd like to see Jana
scratching off the names as we go okay
go ahead
he took my guy so uh so with my second
pick I'm gonna go with my second African
brother
Bhaskar yeah the world yes the first
time all-star can having a great year
with with the Raptors all right LeBron
oh that's that was a good pick right
there Yanis that was gonna be my next
pick oh my goodness I was gonna take
passed out for sure okay so with Pascal
off the board with my third pick I'm
gonna take Luca donkeys whoo so Luca
Luca hoping and then to play he's been
he's been out with the right ankle
sprain but hoping to be available for
the all-star game and I'm hoping I'm
hoping he's available I'm hoping he's
available
he's got three two guys that patent his
game after him and land
all right Yanis oh okay this is a tough
one
I'm between came by train young well you
know what I got a good on what the
dribbler I want somebody that's gonna
pass the ball around so i'ma go with
crossover killer step back master Kimble
walk walk all right you can see that
coming
well he needs a guardian is a point
guard okay
with the last with the last pick and the
draft for me because I know he can play
the point guard position he plays at all
year he's been doing it for the last few
years
i'ma go with the beard James Harden
NBA's leading scorer goes to LeBron with
his last pick of the starters which
leaves Trey young going to team Yanis to
round out his starting five ice tray so
now the fun starts
ice tray so this to me is when you
become a general manager this is the pot
that you fill these this team up with
yeah it's gonna be interesting but when
you're Yanis and you've got the first
pick of the reserves I got a pretty good
offer direction he's going to be going
with this with this first pick so so
with my first big I really don't know
this it's our decision that's it I'm
going getting first but I didn't promise
you this year it's all about waiting for
me no I'm joking I'm gonna go you had
hey LeBron who you LeBron who are you
looking at or who are you whispering to
show general matter who are you getting
some counsel I gotta keep I got to keep
this airtight I got to keep it airtight
snitches get stitches so what's the
consensus there what are you being who
are you being told should no no I'm just
saying because he you know because I
have my list and I'm saying okay I hope
Yanis don't take I hope Yanis don't take
so you know but I kind of had I kind of
figured that Yanis would take Chris yeah
with this first pick in the second round
as I took ad with my first pick in the
first round so I'm gonna go with the guy
who's averaged 50 points over the last
seven games it was that time yes it is
damian lillard going to the team LeBron
a couple of games of over 60 this season
yes crazy for Dane Lillard
alrighty honest what's the book tell you
now and that was my pick actually he
took my pig named Ella but I need
somebody's gonna play hard I'm gonna
play hard I need somebody's gonna play
hard so I'm gonna go with BAM Adebayo
early BAM first time all start getting
picked early in his book lateness
all-stars that's respect right there he
deserves if he's little great this year
that's respect go call ya what you're
thinking LeBron yes that's it that's a
good call right there and I need to
match
Yanis when he says someone that plays
extremely hard sighs so I'm gonna go
with Ben Simmons Ben Simmons of the
Sixers going to you had it affect you
you finagled a trade last year to get
Ben Simmons did you not and now you were
able to draft him in the and I'm able to
draft him I'm able to drive from this
year without a tray yeah I didn't have
to give up assets you know it works out
for me this year
go ahead your honors that that trade
last year custom of the games so I gotta
go with the Eiffel Tower Rudy Gobert
whoo I need somebody to block shots yeah
the stifle tower and a first time
all-star congratulations to Rudy Gobert
seven years in the league and finally an
all-star LeBron
so with him taking Rudy I want to match
size for size I'm going to take the
Joker who Nikola yogic I'll tell you
what's amazing if the United States
played against a foreign team it'd be a
hell of a game or yes hey we might need
to talk about that but we get to that
later we get to that I did good one job
be honest what you think
okay I think I'm gonna go with I'm gonna
go with Jimmy Jimmy Butler he's having a
great year and I think he's going matcha
he's gonna play well with BAM Adebayo
good call you know it's very good if you
look at their teams these both the guys
are like-minded players that they're
choosing of them dude they're all
Allstars
no but I'm talking about style of play
there's no bad air is that like you
don't you didn't play like dr. J but
their style of play all right
LeBron you're up okay with my next pick
because I like we got to fill the wing
spot a little bit more I'm gonna go with
first-time all-star Jason Tatum that I
can tell that dis that disappointed you
you're honest yeah that was all right I
have an idea okay so Simon go with a guy
that's really great in the locker room
cost me the trip to the finals last year
but still a great guy I'll go with Kyle
Lori Oh Kyle Lowry of the Raptors
creating a lock of them yeah and I say
that goofball
so five names still up on that board
rounds five right there
so with my next pick
so he took Kyle Lowry which is the
Bulldog of the East I want to go with a
bulldog from the West so I'm gonna take
Chris Paul great pick
Chris Paul returning to the all-star
game for the first time in a few years
and obviously one of the main reasons
Oklahoma City's having the year they are
having one of eleven games over 500 now
they know us amazing them to see
I'll take those now it's four got those
four guys is left on the board and we
got a chance to win in this oh you can
get a guy off the street to go with them
for all right next up with my next pick
I'll pick a guy that's having a great
season
helping his team do great things I just
played him a couple nights ago Kevin I'm
in Brandon Ingram first time all-star
all right LeBron with my second-to-last
pick of the reserves I'm gonna take
mister why not Russell Westbrook I'm
surprised Russell was still there at
this point not really I mean anybody you
like it chuck them for could have the
second and third either conference yeah
and I love some bonus yeah well let's
see well let's see we're we're Yanis
will go with his life in my last big I
go with my guide done about Mitchell
Donovan Mitchell of the Utah Jazz a
mate's that means yes that means that de
Montes Sabonis a first time all-star for
the Indiana Pacers he's gonna be great
in this format - yeah on team LeBron so
the pics have all been made we're going
to take a break we're going to come back
let you guys break down your
Buster's see if there's any way you want
to tweak them at all and maybe not cost
yourself a game and we'll be right back
[Music]